私は鉄鋼を製造する会社で働き始めました。
今
は製造業者のアニメーションで会社を経営してい
ます。私の後ろに見えるような製造業者のアニメーションは、製造業者という言葉を聞いても誰も目をつぶることはありません。
奇妙なことに、
アニメーションは、アニメーター
やクリエーターを知っているアーティストと呼ばれるこれらの人物によって作成されていると
思いますが
、実際、日本では通常、製造業とは関係がない
ようなものがあります。 ここのクリエイティブ業界の私たちには、私たち
がエキセントリックになりがちな一般的なステレオタイプのいくつかがあり
ます。私たちのクリエイティブな
努力が私たちの生活のほとんどを引き継いで
おり、ACLU
が私たちの
地獄の日光が真夜中
や朝の時間帯になるのが良いプロジェクトは、本当の本当の
創造性がnに設定されるときです
チームワークのスケジュールされた予算や神々しい
締め切りのようなものはあまりありません。アートは進化するの
に独自の時間が必要であり、それは
個人的な孤独なプロセスであることを彼らは知らないの
です。
要するに
、私たちは
あなたが知っている小さな創造的な泡に隔離され
、社会が作り出したタイプと
管理から疎外されている人々が単純に混ざっていないように見えると見られていますが、
今日はそうでなければ
アニメーション制作は実際には
非常に 複雑で規律のあるプロセス
、そして同様に関係者は
芸術的に才能があるだけで
なく、規律のない創造性は、私が鉄鋼会社に参加した直後に九州
の製鉄所でインターンしたときに実際に管理することができ
ます-あなたの施設のサイズ
彼の操作の複雑さとそれ
を支配するすべての高度な技術とは対照的です
が、ほとんどの場合、私は
そこで働く人々が
彼らの情熱と意欲をどのように捧げたかに感銘を受けました
前任者が
火やその他の自然現象を制御する能力を利用し
、炉を爆破
してコンピューターやセンサーを使用してより良い鋼を作成する方法などの作業ストーリーについて話をするたびに、彼らの目が開いて明るくなった
ことを覚えています。
そのよう
な繊細な操作は、数十年の経験を持つマスター職人
の目と感覚と直感に翻弄され、
そのようなマスターは
、人間のタッチがコンピューターに引き継がれる可能性があることを非常に疑っていたため、何年も前には考えられなかったように見え
まし
た。 それとその結果、彼らは
より一貫性のある非常に大量の鋼を生産することができました
これと他の
話は私を魅了しました
そして私がうっかり
デジタルアニメーションの分野に飛び込んだとき私は
アニメーションを作るプロセスがたくさんあったことに嬉しく驚きました 製造ラインの製造と同様に製造から塗装されたものは
、特定の人々によって形成された人間です
材料
が下流の
データフローを流れ、鋼製品
や自動車の代わりにアニメーションコンテンツが
製造
さ
れるため、icの専門分野と職務はすべて一体となって機能します。アニメーションコンテンツを詳しく説明するプロセスを
すばやくご案内します。 そして
再び物語は王様です物語
は偉大な監督の心から来ているかもしれません
し、
シドニアの騎士と呼ばれる私たちの社内制作の
場合のように、この場合は偉大な芸術家トム・ムーニーによって書かれた出版された漫画から来ているかもしれません
ねえ 次に、このストーリー
はスクリプトに変換されます。
ストーリーに到着したすべての要素を設計
し、視覚的な連続性を確保するためにストーリーボードを作成する必要があります。
これらすべての要素やその他の
要素は、アニメーションの製造で言うことができる青写真
であり、設計がすべて
変換されます。  CGモデルのモデリングは
、コンピューター内でスカルプトするようなもので
、画面に表示されるものはすべてモデリングである必要があります。
ヒーローのロボット、
ヒロイン、悪役の宇宙船の
環境、そして
ヒーロー
がアゲナを超えるために先に豚を食べなければならないので、すべてではありませんが
、空の胃で戦うことはできないので、アニメーターに自由を与える
モデルにスケルトンとリグが実装されています
アニメーターを制御し、これらのコントロールを使用して
、フレームごとにアニメーション化する無生物のオブジェクトに生命を吹き込みます。
プロの才能のあるアニメーターの1日の作業では、
1日あたり3〜5秒のアニメーションしか読み取れないため、多くのアニメーションが必要になります。
彼らは協力
して22分のエピソードを完成させるために協力して作業します。ライター
は、屋内、屋外、夏、秋、夜など、シーンへの移動を提供し
ます。これらの要素はすべて
、ネットワークメッシュで計算され、3700は、プロジェクトごとに
900万を超えるファイルをコンパイルするcpuのコンポジットを認識し
ます。 アニメーションショー
を制作する過程で57テラバイトを超えるデータを利用して
、Cydoniaの騎士団を軽く紹介します。
12か国から集まった170人の人々
が、生涯の23万6800時間に貢献し、4
万3000のタスクを完了して、
8400ショットにコンパイルし、
最終的には528
分の完成したアニメーション
を作成します。 一息でそれをぼかす
ので、実際にそれを幸運にやっていると想像してみてください。
プロダクションプロダクションマネージャーに関与しているのはアーティストだけではありません。
環境
良好な対面のコミュニケーションは
時々少し
です海外のパートナーとの会議システムも
同様に重要です良好なコミュニケーションは
依然として成功する生産の基礎です
ので、
芸術性だけ
が料理に関与する要素ではないことがわかると思います アニメーションショーの
芸術性を構造
プロセスと優れた管理と組み合わせて
それが創造性の唯一のレシピなので
、製造業が管理と運用に関して蓄積した
膨大な量の知識と専門知識を調達
し、それらを
間違いなく最大のボリュームと最大のボリュームを生み出すアーティストの素晴らしい才能の基盤と組み合わせることができれば、これが私の希望です
世界の多様なアニメーションコンテンツは完全
にゲームの頂点
に立つことができ、この
目的のためにグローバルベースで何度もカイゼンの練習を行い
、効率を改善し、
技術の進歩
を正直に行います。
効率性を重視することは創造性に反する
ため、製造業で非常に効果的なカイゼンの実践は
創造的な努力には当てはまらないと言うアーティストからの反発がありました-ダンは常に
爆風炉の同じ話を引用し
て彼らに反発しました 製鉄所の人々は、
火事
やその他の自然現象を制御して賭けをする方法を考案しました
コンピューターを使用したtersteelとこれ
により、絶え間ないKaizenを通じて、
あなたの心と行動は
火事や自然現象よりも不安定で予測不可能
であると私に言います。しばらくすると、
実際に重要な結果が見られ始め
ました。 ワークフロー
が改善されたために芸術が気づき始めたとしても、芸術
はもはや
面倒な反復的で
不必要なタスクを処理する必要がなくなり
、代わりに、
創造性を阻止するイニシアチブがそれを強化する代わりに、実際の創造的なものに節約して仕事を改善することに費やすことができます。
私たちのテレビ番組トランスフォーマープライムと称賛のための複数のエミー賞の受賞からの最終的な承認のうなずきは
、これまで映画のアカデミー賞を受賞したことに相当します私
は他の業界から借りたものについて話しました
が、これは
1つの管理原則です
内面から学んだこと、そして
他のすべてを優先すること
私が言ったのは、毎朝起きているのは
モチベーション管理だと思います。
私たちが自分自身と家族に提供し
なければならない根本的な理由で仕事をしていることを確認
してください。 私たちのビジネスでは
、
人々が笑ったり、笑ったり、怒りを感じ
たり、悲鳴を上げたりして、
視聴者の感情を刺激する
ように設計された製品を製造しています。
それはそれだけである
か、うまくいかないので、ロケット科学ではないことをどのように確認するのですか？
しかし、それは簡単ではありません。私たちは
ビッシュマンである必要があります。
観客からのフィードバックを
誇りに思うことができると私たちが信じて
いるプロジェクトでは
、
これらのものを作成する職場は私たちの
究極の報酬
です。 精神的および
肉体的に健康である
ために、私たちは仕事をしないのとほぼ同じくらい多くのエネルギーをパーティーに費やします。
なぜなら、それ
はお祝いと協調、
そして外向的な雰囲気を育むと感じているからです。
家族や愛する人と一緒に時間
を過ごし、人生を探求する時間を過ごして感謝します
が、これは私たちの業界にのみ固有のものであるとは
思わないので、すべての
ビジネスが楽しく
なければなりません。
他の業界から学ぶのと同じように、すべての企業
がイノベーションと効率を追求しなければならないのと
同じように、他の
業界では
、一種の風変わりな奇妙な
狂気の男ではなく
、製品やサービスの改善のための真のインスピレーションを求めてください。
今日、人々は
ソフトウェアだけを購入したり、ハードウェアを購入し
たりするのではなく、他の私たちから学んだように、適切な感情的なリフトを与える総合的な製品を購入しています。
管理と運用の問題に関する業界は、真のコラボレーションを通じてのみ、製品とサービスに非常に重要な感情的要素
を追加する方法について私たちに注目する必要が
あります。
新しい製品とサービスを真に
新しいものにすることができます。これを実行しましょう。
これはそれほど奇妙なことではありません。 楽しいですありがとう